dati i ragazzi questo video sono a
parigi oggi sono con pietro e con lei la
metà però perché chi ha problemi
connessi riparlare un bel gioco ciò che
è più briosa zitti tutti che devo fare
la intro giochiamo in tre oggi oggi
picchiamo pietro se d'accordo camper
fissiamo via rossi ragazzi di allora
però siete delle streghe dovete prendere
la sembianza di un oggetto di questo lo
sapete già
e io vi devo trovare perché sono un
ciccione o meglio agire corpulento che
tenta di trovare le streghe si sono
comportate entrambi qualsiasi cosa in
una piastrella in una bottiglia in un
naufrago in pietro in quello che volete
ragazzi quindi viva la fantasia arrivò
solo ritrovare pietro come primo allora
io ho sbagliato subito il potere perché
il mio potere del primo con la
principale minaccia alla gallina che mi
dice se c'è qualcuno vicino il
secondario o sbagliato perché hai fatto
questo perché perché sarà passamonti da
lì gente per tutti colpisci vicino a
distante non ho capito colpisco anche la
distanza di comino dove siete
se siete veramente nascosti validi per
qualcuno ma visto per ora a io ti vedo
in continuazione da qui si vede tutto ok
e questo è un ottimo indizio dietro che
ti sei messo
spero che te lo dico quando stai facendo
maledizione perché io c'ho questa roba
qua che ho sacrificato il rampino faccio
sta roba che tira una botta per terra
fortissimo che errata non è male come
idea potrebbero vedere come è tempo di
per dare ai file un po matti re lorenzo
a voi un'altra roma mentre di cerco mi
sottovaluti così tanto vieni qua a siena
base into mannaia l'operaio però che ci
fosse pietro non mai poter no no
maledizione è quindi rimasta solo pietro
ma la gallina ragazzi e un impotente
[Musica]
per me non picchiarmi che ti faccio ma
non potrei amare al ragazzino ma dove
vai sei una banana sei un casco di
banane quanto sia allora da dove io sono
un master in questo modo solo perché
devo settori i tasti è anche la prima
era per i bimbi ragazzi tocca a me
nascondermi allora abbiamo indizi it out
musica un sound si può fare il dow con
numero 2 ma con 12 si può fare si può
richiamare l'avversario è già e siete
uomini lo fa a 3 io l'ho fatto e lo sto
facendo ritrovare per prima pietra in
tutto questo ma cosa vuoi da me alla
legge indizi dio inizitive indizi acqua
acqua che muova nell'acqua per mou
secondo non intende che va dall acqua
acqua no no no con il senso di
nell'acqua altissima acquisti amico mio
qualcuno secondo el in cima all'albero
però ancora un po pochino attenzione
potrebbe essere no non li non li all
acqua acqua
qualcosa potrebbe avvicinarsi o mancato
il rampino essa ma perché lo sei anche
tu la dizione eri giusto prima paga ma
hanno fatto un orso con le banane è ok
ma parla per te perché di parlare con me
ma guarda che noi ha visto almeno per
portarti da me è tutto e proprio fuoco
poco noli girati dietro a sinistra c'è
una casa edizione entra dentro la barca
vacca lo guidava la pietra energia nella
vita o la gallina canta anche bernie ora
ma chissà perché sua anima vieni qua
ma come ma dai
ci credo ma come fatto scappare
non lo so ma come facciamo non c'è ma va
via non poi c'è l'amore che ti dicevo
avere quella parte tu sì sì e le
dall'aler sono crediti in giro non mi
fido va bene fatto gli indizi che
impossibile c'è chi stiamo veramente
guidando nuovo farlo anch'io ma tutti
dobbiamo fare che indica solo tu mancato
fama come pratali lorenzo mammamia gene
i primi due posti info sinistri
aiutatemi del reperto è un grande
indizio pietro non lo so ma mi sono i
bersagli avevano capito lui parola
capito proprio lui distratto da te
milano c'è un cimitero
anzi sta guardando che salti
[Musica]
ciao al pollice verde lorenzo e anche la
maglia fermo la non accoglienza che
pirla voleva vivere una coppia un
cagnolino ultimi l'osso sostenne ci
crede lui ci credi cinema no perché ma
maria quella vera e dei vincoli
nell'atto non so se dargli una mano
guardo al mio caso e mina scena dt la
scena di brega meraviglioso ma dai
svezia di scaletta le coppie sono copie
pedoni conosci i potenti questo gioco
assolutamente no
da allora se tu lanci una gallina la
galina al punto esclamativo io sono in
quel punto mi ha fatto fare uccidere da
lui
infatti come è possibile amico sono io
questo non è vero
te lo giuro 26 dove guardi dietro l
incidente cimitero basta a me non piace
questo gioco io non riesce lo stesso del
carso a me la rete si vede vento
transfer porcava che scarsa attenzione
si vedeva quando ho fatto il transfer
ripeto non si vedesse ma te lo giuro
hanno convinto sì vabbè dai io ho
calciato reggio e streghe già temi e non
so dove che spara
le una gabbia sotterranea grafico si dia
inizio al gioco allora amico non so che
poteri ai però vorrei darti una mano per
sfruttarli infatti di sfruttare ci sto
cercando tu mi stai cercando a me certo
il contrario stanno facendo
ho visto una roba è vista per sbaglio
perché ce ne saranno sapevo sta roba che
ci sei jumps caristo gioco è un potere
avola che figata però non avevo idea
quindi tu poi bersagli amico jump
scherma le detto più o meno
poi dopo per evitare perché se perché
non sapevo prenderti però mio figlio non
lo sapevo allora mio amico pietro
conoscendolo secondo me invece non equa
voi invece attenzione attenzione ostia
che è successo qua dopo la vuoi smettere
di fare copie che l'mi6 guida pezzo di
fango ti sta guidando quando quanto
fattivo pietro ad un cielo recava da un
terriccio beverly ma la gallina a
galline già perché ti porta le coppie
aveva portata dentro perché voleva
poteva farmi chiamare dei cie succedendo
veramente la poi prende malissimo
devo ancora capire che ci sono dietro
formule dietro per il potere
oggi mi mise corso dietro per fare è
ovvio non ti ho visto proprio a chi sta
correndo ma sei troppo veloce raga non
mi vedo lo giuro ma io vedo la terra è
fatta però mi sono arrivato era arrivato
d'acqua tipo sbaglio ma edizione
arriverà tipo dritto maledizione guarda
ma va bene
ma dai ti manca una patata sola però non
vale dove ammazzato in un colpo solo un
uomo che cosa vuol dire stare
ottima partenza pietro
ottima partenza cioè partito morto
bruciato
ma scusa un attimo ma come possiamo dire
come fa come ma scusami ma gli otto
colpito un miliardo di volte come fa
essere vivo non era pietro e credo che
farà vino
[Musica]
io l'ho colpito un sacco di volte a
pietro che mi fa essere come ha fatto
essere vivo pietro come l'ho colpito
quanta vita e uno ha capito hai
veramente una capire cielo colpito un
miliardo di volte moriva ceo giuro
incredibile sono sacrificato per
salvarlo ma ringrazia mamma si vedono i
funghi che brutta ma siamo contenti una
volta ma ti avevano colpito un via bakù
al abusivi come hai fatto perché magari
più vita italiana è la più brava per
questo piace sempre per quella va bene
easy ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
ciò il green screen storto ma chi se ne
frega cosa il bisonte mi piace
supportate di cornici che la torre su
which it non è vero ne ringrazio camper
ringrazio anche già perché hai
partecipato un sacco grazie mille sport
bravo grazie alle partecipate e noi ci
rivediamo come sempre hanno persino rito
iscrivetevi spiace da campanella diventa
giocatrici vite passate anche la carta
indietro e noi giulia ciao
[Musica]